i due ladri che sei gasparin o se
vivremo una storia di notare mai inter
film mamma ho perso l'aereo
lo stesso attore c'è staremo a casa da
soli a natale ma arriveranno i ladri tra
super divertente credetemi comodi preti
pop corn state un mi piace iniziamo
subito alla storia nel frattempo che
aspettiamo che il gioco facciamo noi un
gioco lo stato mi piace questo l'ultima
cifra del vostro mi piace corrisponde a
colta o potreste ricevere il permesso
poi ci sono dei regali e l'ultima cifra
del vostro mi piace è stregata da alcuni
sono regali divertente federico 20 cosa
vi è capitato che iniziavano così
entusiasta di andare a parigi dovremo
fare le valigie anche a noi e proprio
come il film che esistono di fatto lo
per parisi ma queste ti metti che lo di
lui poverino ciao ragazzi sono kevin
sono contento che veniate con noi a
parigi mentre ma insieme a parigi un pò
strano questa cosa ragazzi dovreste
esplorare la casa prima di fare
qualsiasi altra cosa andate avanti ok
esploriamo la calma e allora qui c'è
l'albero di natale wow abbiamo cercare
che cosa dobbiamo trovare momenti allora
qui c'è la ciotola del gattone
grandissima la casa c'è anche la stanza
dei giochi è visto il computer il
piano di sopra già finito il tempo
volevo esplorare di più la mamma ha
detto che dobbiamo fare le valigie che
andiamo a fare le valigie cerca i
vestiti in questa stanza e ho trovato 11
si prende così breve annuncio presiedute
devi prenderli tutti tutti bene ora
possiamo essere sentito un botto che
cos'era che cos'era quel rumore dico io
sono già arrivati i ladri a come il ben
più allegro
[Musica]
quelle ozmen jolly siamo noi stiamo
lontani da lui ok ok
dicono che sia un assassino non me lo
ricordavo così mamma ho perso l'aereo ma
poi alla fine era una prova persona
misura cestino dove tiene tutti i suoi
corpi
accese
presto prendi la moto si l'ho presa
sorpresa dove sarà non lo so però
indicano si può andare scendiamo penso
che la scena sia pronta è quanto si
tratta di mangiare non c'è problema ma
sono sempre pronto ecco la mappa ok va
bene a tutti portiamo dopo di mattina
quindi mangiate ora sappiamo se tutti a
tavola con l'amata
mamma questa cena è terribile ma
poverina kevin come ti permetti come osi
dirlo topa a tua madre
ero solo onesto nero sono sincero e
tutto che vinse in time out per il resto
della notte prima che questi di
punizione ma è soffitta tu e tutti i
tuoi amici ma cose per come volete ma io
voglio mangiare così in soffitta
ci sono file finire la mamma e un po
malefica resta qui fino al mattino the
sveglierò quando partiremo per parigi
ma insomma vorrei che non dovessimo mai
più vedere a nessuno di voi ragazzi
mente sono forse verso la madre del
padre
ha offeso la mamma ha chiuso la porta
vabbè andiamo a dormire dice kevin
almeno domani andiamo a parigi ok
qualcosa mi dice che domani non andremo
a parigi ok allora trovo ecco come
dormiamo pro posarlo
dall'area la pizza la casa nella
maglietta e beh non mi hanno fatto
neanche mangiare guarda allora ci siamo
addormentati
ma sta piovendo si
è soli 25 ladri o amico non vedo l'ora
che questa famiglia all'emozione vado
anch'io trapani romana casa vuota è così
facile
contro andiamo riposarci un po prima di
rubare tutto in questa casa domani sono
le 11 svegliatevi tutti siamo in ritardo
o no sono le 11 dovevamo partire due ore
fa
molto bella andiamo a svegliare gli
adulti dove sono al piano di sotto trova
gli adulti ok andiamo trovati
sbrighiamoci perché si sono qui i ladri
che aspettavo che schiaccerà andiamo
legale vadano per entrare in casa non ci
sono non ci sono partiti il gioco di noi
come delfini come
uno con noi scaduto il tempo dividete da
qualche parte non controlliamo il
seminterrato
come si fa ad andare non se n'è parlato
qualcuno si spizzicate opachi o
interrato ed esplora il seminterrato non
lo trovo o no davvero
troppo eseguite non capisco bene
a ecco questa scena il film
ho paura di quella fornace torniamo
sopra
wow li abbiamo davvero tutti fatti
sparire il nostro desiderio si è
avverato quindi praticamente ha sperato
che tutti i familiari espressero
possiamo fare tutto ciò che vogliamo
siamo liberi wow intanto in aerei
avranno ricordatevi che la madre e il
padre mi sembra che stiamo dimenticando
qualcosa se tua figlia
tu pensi sempre pensare rilassarti va
tutto bene
ci siamo dimenticati di lei
intanto fuori casa che bella che proprio
per rivivere il film è vero ecco i due
ladri o amico la famiglia lemon è
finalmente partita per la settimana non
vedo l'ora di derubare quella casa sarà
così facile invece per iniziare
qualcuno ha sentito il rumore della
portiera dell'auto
che sarebbe quindi a quest'ora giusto
sono rapidamente l'interruttore della
luce esterna e accendi la luce
ok trovai dove dovete fare è quello che
hanno trovato
[Musica]
ok ma se sono le luci ecco i ladri
pensavo che nessuno dovesse essere a
casa che hanno visto le loro stime
sarebbero dovuti partire tutti per
parigi questa mattina una tote torniamo
alle 9 in punto quando nessuno sarà in
caso di pensate che nessuno era in casa
ma ci entreremo mai ad aspettarvi quei
due strani stavano cercando di
svaligiare la nostra casa dobbiamo
essere preparati per quanto tornano e se
andiamo al negozio a comprare le
provviste righe come nel bellissimo non
è uguale wow del negozio ok ragazzi
abbiamo bisogno di martello con con la
corda e legno dividiamo se troviamo lì
ok martello corda con
io competiamo ho trovato qualcosa
non so che cosa era questa del legno
io lo trovo niente dai bric amaie c'è
qualcosa io ho trovato il martello
abbiamo già trovato tutto wow torniamo a
casa non vedo l'ora di propalare troppo
dai ladri e gli scherzi seguimi andiamo
a casa a piedi ok bisogna stare attenti
a teniamo kevin
kevin
perché c'è un camion un furgone che ci
segue i ladri
e il furgone dei rapinatori presto
dobbiamo pre per dobbiamo seminarli
conosco la scorciatoia seguimi ok
sbrighiamoci si stanno seguendo solo
dietro sbrigati
meno male che fini con noi ma è infatti
bellissimo così gioco sembra proprio di
vivere il film per chi ha voce
la nostra casa è proprio di fronte a
questo lago il lago ghiacciato quindi
dovrebbe essere dovrebbe essere sicuro
il lago ghiacciato quindi dobbiamo
attraversarlo
proprio comune skype room o no è
bellissimo non abbiamo scelta saltiamo
di traverso presto sistema meno attento
a non morire mi raccomando o no poverino
una giocatrice è affondata
aiutato
[Musica]
ci siamo forti escludendo il tempo h 16
secondi
[Musica]
bruciata viva ma che io non ci posso
crederci mi comprava capitale non ti
seguiamo kevin sono gli altri giocatori
mi sa che siamo rimasti solo in tre in
due pro finalmente di una casa il
vecchio a
il vecchio jolly ciao ragazzi potrete
davvero usare un dollaro ma vuole figli
diamo un dollaro
stai lontano da roy vecchio ma non si
dice così per favore dice lui diamogli
un dollari
secondo me ci aiuterà grazie infatti nel
gioco nel nel film poi lui ci aiuta
quindi forse ci aiuterà
ok siamo tornati a casa ok anche quello
di non portare le nostre difese
ma quanti sono dobbiamo mettere la legna
alle finestre che sono tantissime noi
siamo solo in due dobbiamo fare
velocissimo ok abbiamo
aiuto io comincio qui dalla porta
principale è che io mi sono una alla
volta bisogna volare come facciamo per
telecom no impossibile è davvero
difficilissimo
troppe posso metterlo in giostra
finestre settimane uno qua
keratea preghiamo di
oggi ci sono tantissimi
kevin aiutate i capitelli un altro nome
noto notte riusciranno a entrare
sicuramente ci vogliono non sono buttato
va bene basta dice kevin sono le nove in
punto tranquillo dovrebbe essere qui
domina dall'alto dovrebbero essere
finalmente questo proiettore conditi
surprise sorpresa
sappiamo che ci sei
abbiamo
tutti gli saltano
anni montatori stessa perché dimetto
perché diverto back di questo scarpata
siamo troppo forti per loro
siamo troppo folti porno ragazzi siete
sfortunati
allora o no tieni una mazzata freddo
aiutami
ma come ogni barca buco eccolo qua
dietro o no o quasi consumato tutta la
vita
ok maturi vvt morto agli ottavi da
aiutami mai doma perché ambiente
difficilissimo i due
presto ho capito dobbiamo scaricare solo
scappare non riusciremo a sconfiggerlo
tavoli dove potevo dire che tu ti
[Musica]
devi nasconderti deve scappare
continuazione
affatto andate giù nel seminterrato
devono essere interrato almeno siamo
nascosti dobbiamo nascondere chiede il
resto tutti si nascondono allarmato e
vicino alla fornace
qui
qualcosa mi dice che i ladri arriveranno
anche qua ecco che sono arrivati
lì non ti muovere o nell'altro ladro si
è mark si sta cercando
dobbiamo andarcene da qui possa
accendere il fuoco per distrarlo poi
corriamo di sopra ok
nota
sta accendendo il fuoco
corridore carreggiata
vorremmo che abbiamo parliamo premo
bravo prova
ma che stava al piano di sopra
non possiamo restare in questa casa dove
possiamo andare adesso seguimi di sopra
ok ma sopra dove io sono stato preso
purtroppo ho perso la vita le statali
per questo quadro
c'è un'altra casa sull'altra eccoli
steroli
ragazzi ora siete intrappolati dicono i
ladri a utah usa le tue armi per
sconfiggere i ladri non ce la farò mai
ce l'ha fatta ora abbiamo state
richiamate scappare dove lo potrà fare
non lo so vai fuori dalla finestra e
salta verso la piazza sull'albero
attendono chiedere
aiuto sbrigati perché sul tempo
promosso
piano prendi l'anno in corso
ci sono quasi
bravissimo
vero i ladri sono laggiù però che non si
raggiungano quatto aiuto non devi per
cui sono li guarda
eccoli
pensi di essere scappato stiamo
arrivando
e ora che cosa devo fare trovano le
forbici dove sono e con il quale
ho capito tagliamo la cosa ma così
allora cadranno wow sono caduti
dobbiamo bruciare l'albero proprio con
noi c'è ancora vita sei sicuro sembra un
po folle prodigio di mark
ogni vecchio jolly
che fatto perché noi lo abbiamo aiutato
voi ragazzi mi avete aiutato e quindi io
ho aiutato voi grazie
bravo ha vinto il premio presule non è
buono in più anche senza soldi
però abbiamo completato la storia anche
di evitare purtroppo è stato preso tutto
questo sondaggio è stato
divertente e meno male abbiamo aiutato
il vecchietto che ci ha salvato però
alla fine ha salvato lasciate un bel mi
piace vi lasciamo qua quattro case
lynette squeaky care per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite